[Applause]
on March 23rd 2013 users worldwide
discovered in their newsfeed a video of
a young girl being raped by an older man
before this video was removed from
Facebook it was already shared 16,000
times and it was even liked 4,000 times
this video went viral and infected the
net and that was the moment we asked
ourselves how could something like this
get on facebook and at the same time why
doesn't we see such content more often
after all there's a lot of revolting
material online but why do we so rarely
see such crap on Facebook Twitter or
Google while image recognition software
can identify the outlines of sexual
organs blood or naked skin in images and
videos it has immense difficulties to
distinguish pornographic content from
holiday pictures Adonis statues or
breast cancer screening campaigns it
can't distinguish Romeo and Juliet dying
on stage from a real knife attack it
can't distinguish satire from propaganda
or irony from hatred and so on and so
forth therefore humans are needed to
decide which of the suspicious content
should be deleted and which should
remain humans whom we know almost
nothing because they work in secret they
sign non-disclosure agreements which
prohibit them from talking and sharing
what they see on the screens and what
this work does to them they are forced
to use code words in order to hide who
they work for they are monitored by
private security firms in order to
ensure that they don't talk to
journalists and they are threatened by
fines in case they speak all of this
sounds like a weird crime story but it's
true these people exist and they are
called Content moderators we are the
directors of the feature documentary
film the cleaners and we would like to
take you to a world that many of you may
not know yet here's a short clip of our
film
[Music]
they need to be anonymous because we
have a contract sign-in we are not
allowed to declare whom we are working
with the reason why I speak to you
because the world should know that we
are here
there is somebody who's checking the
social media we are doing our best to
make this platform safe for all of them
[Music]
ignore it
the so-called content would raters don't
get their paychecks from Facebook
Twitter or Google themselves but by
outsourcing firms around the world in
order to keep the wages low tens of
thousands of young people looking at
everything we are not supposed to see
and we are talking about decapitations
mutilations executions Negro philia
torture child abuse thousands of images
in one shift ignore deletes day and
night and much of this work is done in
Manila where the analog toxic waste from
the Western world was transported for
years by container ships now the digital
waste is dumped there by a fiber-optic
cable and just as the so called
scavengers room age threw a gigantic
tips on the edge of the city the content
moderator clicked their way through an
endless toxic ocean of images and videos
and all manner of intellectual garbage
so that we don't have to look at it but
unlike the wounds of the scavengers
those of the content moderators remain
invisible full of shocking and
disturbing content these pictures and
videos burrow into their memories where
at any time they can have unpredictable
effects eating disorders loss of libido
anxiety disorders alcoholism depression
which can even lead to suicide the
pictures and videos infect them and
often never let them go again if they
are unlucky they develop post-traumatic
stress disorders like soldiers after war
missions in our film we tell the story
of a young man who had to monitor life
streams of self mutilations and suicide
attempts again and again and who
eventually committed suicide himself
it's not an isolated case as we've been
told this is the price all of us pay for
our so-called clean and safe and healthy
environments on social media
never before in the history of mankind
has been easier to reach millions of
people around the globe in a few seconds
what is posted on social media spread so
quickly becomes viral and excites the
minds of people all around the globe
before it is deleted it is often already
too late
millions of people have already been
infected with hatred and anger and they
either become active online by spreading
or amplifying hatred or they take to the
streets and take up arms therefore an
army of content moderators sit in front
of a screen to avoid a new collateral
damage and they are deciding as soon as
possible where the content stays on the
platform ignore or disappears delete but
not every decision is as clear as the
decision about a child abuse video what
about controversial content ambivalent
content uploaded by civil rights
activist or citizen journalists the
content moderators often decide on such
cases at the same speed than unclear
cases we will show you a video now and
we would like to ask you to decide what
you deleted or what you not delete it
[Applause]
in Scenario and it's unnatural Jesus
reassured Jesus Amazo Albertville yeah
we did some blurring for you
a child would potentially be dangerously
disturbed and extremely frightened by
such content so you rather delete it but
what if this video could help
investigate the war crimes in Syria what
if nobody would have heard about this
airstrike because Facebook YouTube
Twitter would have decided to take it
down air was a non-government
organization based in London tries to
find those videos as quickly as possible
whenever they are uploaded to social
media in order to archive them because
they know sooner or later Facebook
YouTube Twitter would take such content
down people armed with their mobile
phones can make visible what journalists
often do not have access to civil rights
groups often do not have any better
option to quickly make the recordings
accessible to a large audience than by
uploading them to social media wasn't
this the empowering potential the world
wide web should have learnt these the
dreams people in its early stages had
about the World Wide Web can't pictures
and videos like these persuade people
who have become insensitive to facts to
rethink but instead everything what
might be disturbing is deleted and
there's a general shift in society media
for example more and more often use
trigger warnings at the top of articles
which some people may perceive as
offensive or troubling or more students
at university in the United States
demand the banishment of anti classics
which depict sexual violence or assault
from the curriculum but how far should
we go with that physical integrity is
guaranteed as a human right and
constitutions worldwide in the Charter
of Fundamental Rights of the European
Union
this ride expressly applies to mental
integrity but even if the potentially
traumatic effect of images and video is
hard to predict do we want to become so
cautious that we risk to lose social
awareness of injustice so what to do
Mark Zuckerberg recently stated that in
the future the users we or almost
everybody will decide individually what
they would like to see on the platform
by personal filter settings so everyone
could easily claim to remain undisturbed
by images of war or other violent
conflicts like I'm the type of guy who
doesn't mind seeing breasts and I'm very
interested in global warming but I don't
like war so much yeah I'm more the
opposite I have zero interest in naked
breasts or naked bodies at all but why
not guns I like guns yes come on if we
don't share a similar social
consciousness how should we discuss
social problems how shall we call people
to action even more isolated bubbles
would emerge one of the central
questions is how in future freedom of
expression will be weighed against the
people's need for protection it's a
matter of principle do we want to design
an either open or closed society for the
digital space at the heart of the matter
is freedom versus security Facebook has
always wanted to be a healthy platform
above all users should feel safe and
secure it's the same choice of words the
content moderators in the Philippines
used in a lot of our interviews
it's not really healthy in this world
there's really an evil who exists we
need to watch for it we need to control
it good or bad
[Applause]
[Music]
for the young content moderators in the
strictly Catholic Philippines this is
linked to a Christian mission to counter
the sins of the world which spread
across the web cleanliness is next to
godliness is a saying everybody in the
Philippines knows and others motivate
themselves by comparing themselves with
their president
Rodrigo detector he has been ruling the
Philippines twins since 2016 and he won
the election with a promise I will clean
up and what that means is eliminating
all kinds of problems by literally
killing people on the streets who's
supposed to be criminal whatever that
means and since he was elected an
estimated twenty thousands people have
been killed and one moderator in our
film says were to tear to death on the
streets I do for the internet and here
they are our self-proclaimed super
heroes who enforce law and order in our
digital world they clean up they polish
everything clean they free us from
everything evil tasks formerly reserved
to state authorities have been taken
over by college graduates in their early
20s equipped with a three to five day
training this is the qualification work
on nothing less than the world's rescue
national sovereignties have been
outsourced to private companies and they
pass on their responsibilities to third
parties
it's an outsourcing of the outsourcing
of the outsourcing which takes place
with social networks we are dealing with
a completely new infrastructure with its
own mechanisms its own logic of action
and therefore also its own new dangers
which have not yet existed in a pre
digitalized public sphere when Mark
Zuckerberg was at the US Congress or at
the European Parliament he was
confronted with all kinds of critics and
his reaction was always the same we will
fix that and I will follow up on that
with my team but such a debate shouldn't
be held in backrooms of Facebook
Twitter or Google such a debate should
be openly discussed in new cosmopolitan
parliaments in new institutions that
reflects the diversity of people
contributing to an auto peon project of
a global network and while it may seem
impossible to consider the values of
users worldwide it's worth believing
that there is more that connects us and
separates us yeah at a time when
populism is gaining strength it becomes
popular to just fight the symptoms to
eradicate them to make them invisible
this ideology is spreading worldwide
analog as well as digital and it's our
duty to stop it before it's too late
the question of freedom and democracy
must not only have these two options
delete or ignore thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]